so does an alpha male need an alpha
woman
well what is an alpha woman
it's a great question what is an option
she's uh you're asking me yeah there's
looks like there's one right there
that's well i don't know if i would
consider myself an alpha woman if i
didn't have an alpha male you know
because
truly i do i i seriously think that that
you can mold your relationship however
you want it to be you can and
if
if we had money which is the root of all
of our problems then we would be in such
better position where i can afford
somebody to cook and clean and
provide so and then i can be in my in
you know in my corner be creative and
reach my goal which my goal is to spread
crypto in my country you know nobody
understands crypto or they even have um
you know some challenges with the
country or with the government so
i have bigger goals you know what i mean
that's too clean or cook yeah it's great
i know how to do it i can make my bed i
make my bed every day in the morning
there's got to be something on your mind
right now i feel like you're like
go ahead and get it i was more saying in
a sense that with the cleaning and
cooking she wants to do that for you i
mean no female wants to do that like
come on if a female had an option to do
it something like that some people do
that's their goal like they they're like
i'm done working i just want to be home
for my husband some females do that why
would you not want to feed your man
i would i would feed my man and i do of
course it's i'm just telling you that
when you have a bigger goal in mind
right like for example
making a whole country financially free
with crypto there is better things to do
and waste your time with than cleaning
or cooking and luckily my man
understands this because we have the
same goal to get together you know what
i mean it's a characteristic of an alpha
woman so she's hooked on purpose yep no
no seriously i'm just
i'm just like
i do it and of course i'm not expecting
a person me to be dirty no i'm having a
clean space a clear mind
a clear of what i want to do but i'm not
going to waste my time just cleaning and
doing my laundry like it's truly it's a
waste of what the majority of
relationships don't operate on the way
you operate majority of relationship
isn't i have a woman that's you know a
crypto mogul and she wants to she wants
to she wants to come she's saying that
she's unique and most women are not
you're an exception to the rules i would
say i wouldn't say i'm an exception to
the rule i'm just no not at all i'm just
like eddie are the any other female who
is embracing her femininity okay and
luckily for me my man is allowing that
for me to happen you know and same thing
with him that's why right now i'm in my
prime and that's why he is at his prime
because we're again
understanding what it means to be in a
committed relationship with one another
and
understand what is it the goal that we
want out of life right
let's just establish what we think
you know the exception of the rules are
natalia you'd mentioned that a lot of
women do want to kind of be more of the
housewife they're lying they're lying
okay so here it is i don't think so
everyone else yeah i don't i don't think
they're lying
let's go down the line here well that's
different what percentage of women want
to be the strong independent working
women i.e like you you know and what
percentage of women are a little more
comfortable being you know second place
housewife more the family go ahead let's
get some numbers what percentage do you
think
that for each
i would give
housewife i would say about
maybe like
70. i was thinking the same 70 of women
want to be more independent okay correct
matt go ahead well i i i don't know i
have a zero class i haven't i've been
polled but uh because because when i
when i was dating uh those 14-year
sabbatical i had maybe had six
relationships that lasted for six months
and what turned me off about them is
that they weren't really
uh yeah there was no drive in in what
they wanted to do as a career because
you know housewife and listen i
understand because that's an act of
service and i love it when a woman comes
and he wants wants to a server man
that's awesome my wife does it too she
just called she calls the door dash
right but she always asks what do you
want for dinner what do you want for
dinner so in a way she's not cooking for
me but she's still right she's she's the
nurse and you're making sure yeah she's
taking care of it like the kids like
sheena always takes care of the kids you
know we got to take care of this take
care of that so she has that role she
just doesn't actually
you know get it then we have you know
cleaner do it with the nanny do it
savers do it and we're doing this all
before we were we had money yeah i would
have to say though like if when i have
kids i will for sure be a housewife
because then again as i told you earlier
the success of of me and my family will
be measured of the family i raised and
the children i raised right like what
products am i actually seating right now
so but if you're leaving if you're
leaving your country with crypto yeah
yeah if i'm doing whatever if you're
leading the inclusion of crypto into
your country let's say that happens when
that happens yes that will happen i just
don't know the time and you're leading
it and you're leading it i don't have to
lead it that's the beautiful of crypto
you have the freedom of speech you can
do whatever you want with your krypton
that's what i will teach to people
that's exactly what i'm doing and you
also mentioned that once you have
children that's when you're going to
turn on the switch and become a
housewife wouldn't you say these are
traits that you have to somewhat you
know
growing through
again these are just definitions that
we're we're getting stuck on right we're
second getting stuck on the housewife
just because you're a housewife doesn't
mean that you're not going to be
creative or do anything people think
that just because you're housewife like
you're actually life ends no that's when
you're actually life your life begins
because
you are nourishing your children you are
raising your children
now
luckily i have money i will have help to
make my children emotionally intelligent
so i will have them different teachers
you know yeah of course i will teach
them about myself i'm not sending them
to school that's for sure i'll have
homeschooling but i'm going to have help
why because i can afford it right right
and this is what i'm trying to make
people understand not only i can do it
everybody can do it and especially
nowadays in 2022 it's super easy you
truly just have to
shut up and listen to your men
that's seriously all you have shut up
and listen to your man so that's
essentially saying that let your man be
a leader exactly well that's what
exactly what i'm trying to tell you you
cannot have a strong woman if you're not
going to have a strong leader like the
rest are just pretending like a strong
you know a guy who's very strong with
multiple women he's pretending just to
be like shut up and listen to your man i
want you to cook and clean and that's
all i want you to do well then that
critical thing is not happening but
you're the one that stated shut up and
listen to your man no in the sense of so
it's no no he's saying
no no you're multiple you're like
manipulating you're trying to manipulate
my words what i'm trying to say is that
sometimes especially when it comes to
finances men know more so that's exactly
what i did i listened to my men i became
a millionaire and now we're enjoying the
life together
living life trying to teach people the
same thing
why because i was raised from an amazing
father i had a great base
same thing with my brother you know and
now i was able to pick the right man why
because this was rooted from me since
the beginning since i was a little girl
right so this is exactly what's
happening to me i'm just allowing being
a female my femininity is coming and i'm
just manifesting like i'm seriously just
manifesting stuff and things are
happening to me and if you don't my
accent what was the what role did your
mother play if you don't if my mother
never worked in her life and then we
moved to america she worked because my
dad sold everything that he had in
albania it wasn't much obviously it was
just a third world country moved to
america my mom started working and i can
tell that she's not happy working no
woman is happy really working unless
you're truly doing something
so would you say she was more happier
when she was
a housewife then well right now she's
no longer working as well you know like
just working a little bit um trying
especially because she's into crypto as
well yeah
mom's even in the crypto room
what economic system is albania
or socialism yeah no they're democratic
they're uh
well socialism now if you ask me but
democratic social democratic socialism
yeah they're well they consider
themselves democratic but and again in
my eyes they're socialists and they
don't understand that they're socialists
[Music]